wir schauen auf neue Entwicklungen im
Fall Maddie McCann und diesmal sind die
Eltern involviert die verlieren nämlich
eine Verleumdungsklage gegen den
portugiesischen Chef Ermittler vor dem
Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte bevor wir darüber
sprechen wenn wir noch einmal auf den
wahrscheinlich größten Entführungsfall
der Geschichte blicken
Praia da lusch an der portugiesischen
Algarve hier verschwindet 2007 die
damals dreijährige Maddie Macken
[Musik]
der Fall Maddie McCann ist mit
ziemlicher Wahrscheinlichkeit der größte
führungsfall der Welt
bis heute ermitteln portugiesische
Polizisten Scotland Yard und das
Bundeskriminalamt
Bildreporter Kai Feldhaus auf
Spurensuche in Portugal an dem Ort wo
Maddie verschwand am Abend des dritten
mai 2007 sind es Madels Eltern hier in
dieser Tapas Bar auf der anderen Seite
des Pools beim Abendessen das Apartment
war von der Tapas Bar aus zu sehen man
konnte die Terrasse sehen den Eingang
ist der vorletzte Abend ihres Urlaubs
hier in Praia da Lusche in Portugal die
mir kennt sitzen zusammen mit drei
befreundeten Familien die Erwachsenen
wechseln sich alle halbe Stunde ab und
nach dem schlafenden Kindern zu sehen
gegen 22 Uhr ist Mädels Mutter Kate an
der Reihe sie verlässt also die Tapas
Bar läuft am Pool entlang um zu
Appartement 5a das Ocean Club zu
gelangen das hier im Erdgeschoss dieses
Gebäudes liegt um zum Apartment zu
kommen muss Kate Macan durch die
Rezeption und über diese kleine Straße
laufen als kennt McKellen um 22 Uhr das
Zimmer ihrer Tochter betritt stellt sie
zunächst fest dass sie ein Windzug
entgegen hauckt und bemerkt dann das
Madeleine nicht mehr in ihrem Bett liegt
dieses Fenster das jetzt zehn Jahre
später vergittert ist steht weit offen
kurz darauf ist sie schreiend wieder
rausgelaufen und hat gerufen
jemand hat sie mitgenommen die
portugiesische Polizei sucht im
Ferienappartement nach Sporen unter der
Leitung des damaligen chef-ermittlers
Gonzalo amadral
als ich zum ersten Mal an dem Apartment
in Praia da Luz vorgefahren bin saß dort
nur ein Journalist mit einem Laptop im
Auto kurz danach war niemand mehr da und
nur Stunden später war es als ginge die
Welt unter ein unglaublicher Zirkus
wurde aufgefahren wir hatten überhaupt
keine Möglichkeiten mehr ungestört und
sorgfältig zu arbeiten warum all das es
gibt mehrere Faktoren aber der
wichtigste ist sicher der Wunsch der
Eltern alles zu tun um ihr Image sauber
zu halten die Eltern Gary und Kate mcken
Ärzte aus dem britischen roughly werden
mit Vorwürfen kon
diese Tapas Bar liegt auf dem Gelände
des Ocean Clubs sie ist Teil der Anlage
von der Tapas Bar aus das kann man in
dem Video ja erkennen können Sie auf die
Terrasse ihres Apartments schauen jetzt
10 15 Jahre später nachdem so etwas
passiert ist kann man sagen wie kann man
denn und die Kinder da schlafen lassen
und alleine und so ich halte das gar
nicht für so wahnsinnig abwegig die
Eltern waren keine 50 Meter Luftlinie
entfernt sie haben regelmäßig
nachgeschaut jetzt im Nachhinein wenn
man weiß dass sowas hier passieren kann
dann ist es einfach in der Vorwürfe zu
machen in der Ferienwohnung finden die
Ermittler weder Einbruchspuren noch
Fingerabdrücke einer fremden
personalschaft Braunschweig gegen einen
43-jährigen deutschen Staatsangehörigen
wegen des Verdachtes des Mordes als
medie mckenn verschwindet ist Christian
Brückner wegen mehrerer Sexualdelikte
vorbestraft
2007 lebte in Portugal nur wenige
Kilometer von der Ferienanlage der
McKenzie entfernt
fest steht Christian Brückners
Handynummer war zurzeit in eine
Funkzelle nahe des Ferienapartments
eingewählt sein Wohnhaus zweieinhalb
Kilometer vom Ocean Club entfernt und er
teilte Gewaltfantasien in einem Chat
aktuell ist Christian Brückner in Haft
wegen Vergewaltigung einer Frau im Jahr
2005 die Ermittlungen im Fall Maddie
Macken dauern an und derjenige der den
Vermisstenfall am besten kennt unser
Bild-Chef Reporter Kai Feldhaus jetzt
bei uns im Studio schönen guten Tag Kai
hallo der Fall Maddie mckenn in all den
Jahren noch immer wieder dass ich die
Eltern und die portugiesischen Chef
Ermittler gegenseitig beschuldigen was
ist das besondere an dem Verhältnis
dieser beiden Parteien die Portugiesen
allen voran und saloam der damals ja der
leitende Ermittler war haben sehr früh
damit begonnen die Eltern zu
verdächtigen das mag kriminalistisch
sauber sein wenn man sagt wenn sowas
passiert dann sind die nächsten
Verwandten sehr sehr häufig beteiligt in
diesem Falle wirkt es aber in der in der
Rückschau ein bisschen wie wir brauchen
jetzt mal ein Verdächtigen weil das ist
ja kein Geheimnis am Tatort in der Nacht
des Verschwindens so sehr geschlampt
wurde dass dort kaum brauchbares
Spurenmaterial sichergestellt wurde das
führte dann dazu dass die Eltern
innerhalb von relativ kurzer Zeit einige
Wochen nach dem Verschwinden von
Madeline in den offiziellen Status von
Verdächtigen erhoben wurden und diese
Verdächtigung dieser Ermittlungen wurden
aber dann im Juli darauf eingestellt das
heißt seitdem ist jeder Zweifel gegen
die Eltern polizeilich vorbei das hat
aber den Ermittler gonzale ameral nicht
daran gehindert ein Buch zu schreiben
ein Jahr darauf in dem er die Eltern
immer noch als die Haupt Tatverdächtigen
bezeichnet und seine Theorie quasi auf
250 Seiten untermauert
dass also der Vorgang jetzt gerade ganz
aktuell du hast den Chef Ermittler der
mittlerweile diesen Job nicht mehr hat
auch persönlich kennengelernt lass uns
einmal gemeinsam Einblick bekommen wie
in diesem Fall ermittelt wird und welche
Rolle er darin spielt
ich habe bis heute keine Zweifel dass
eine Entführung dort nur simuliert wurde
es gibt mehrere Anzeichen dafür ein
Fenster von dem niemand sicher sagen
konnte ob es offen oder geschlossen
waren
trotzdem hat man uns erzählt dass der
angebliche Entführer dort hinein und
wieder hinausgeklettert ist
es gab Fingerabdrücke der Mutter des
Kindes die zeigen dass Sie das Fenster
geöffnet hat es waren die einzigen die
gefunden wurden
es gab keine Anzeichen dafür dass die
Jalousie von außen aufgeschoben wurde
und auch sonst keine für einen Einbruch
es wurde eine Entführung behauptet die
nicht stattgefunden hat
wenn der deutsche Staatsanwalt die
portugiesischen Akten noch nicht gelesen
hat was er bestimmt nicht hat es sind
tausende von Seiten dann sollte er es
tun und gut aufpassen es gab in der
portugiesischen Untersuchung nichts das
auf eine Entführung hindeutet ich hatte
sehr bald das Gefühl dass mit den Eltern
etwas nicht stimmt nach nationalen und
internationalen Maßstäben sind die
Hauptverdächtigen im Fall des
Verschwindens eines Kleinkindes
diejenigen die für seine Betreuung und
Sicherheit verantwortlich sind in diesem
Fall die Eltern es ist normal dass Sie
von Anfang an verdächtig sind hier aber
war es nicht der Fall
ja und dieses Buch wollten die Eltern
gerne verhindern die Eltern von Madeline
Macken Kai um was geht es in diesem Buch
was steht darin was sind die Inhalte die
diese Eltern besonders stört besonders
angreift gonzalle hat nicht nur die
Ermittlungen den Vorsitz bei den
Ermittlungen verloren sondern sein
gesamten Job der ist nach 27 Jahren in
der Polizei aus dem Polizeidienst
entfernt worden eben wegen dieser
Vorwürfe und er hat dieses Buch dann
geschrieben wahrscheinlich auf der einen
Seite um sein Lebensunterhalt weiter zu
bestreiten aber auch um seine Theorie
weiter verbreiten zu können und seine
Theorie ist eben die dass nicht ein
Einbrecher ein Entführer von außerhalb
eines Apartment eingedrungen ist sondern
die Eltern selbst möglicherweise
unfallhaft den Tod ihres Kindes
verschuldet haben und das Kind dann
haben verschwinden lassen man muss
einmal explizit sagen es gibt dafür
keine Beweise aber diese Theorie hat er
sehr früh 2008 zu Papier gebracht und
jetzt 14 Jahre später und drei Instanzen
später ist gerichtsfest beschlossen
worden dass er das weiter behaupten darf
was bedeutet das für die Eltern dass
diese Verleumdungsklage jetzt
gescheitert ist und dass der ehemalige
Chef Ermittler seine Thesen eben weiter
behaupten kann und das Buch weiter
verbreitet werden kann das ist natürlich
eine zusätzliche Belastung man muss sich
jetzt vorstellen Kate und Jeremy
McKellen haben ein Kind verloren vor 14
Jahren unter rätselhaften Umständen wir
wissen bis heute nicht was mit dem Kind
passiert ist und jetzt gibt es jemanden
der weiterhin öffentlich behaupten darf
und auch Geld damit machen darf zu
behaupten dass die Eltern selbst daran
Schuld sind er ist jetzt so ein bisschen
vorsichtiger geworden in seiner
Formulierung als wir getroffen haben in
Lissabon vor gut einem Jahr das sagte
halt dass die Schuld am Verschwinden des
Kindes tragen die Menschen die nicht auf
das Kind aufgepasst haben das heißt er
ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz so explizit
aber da war der Fall ja auch noch im
schwanger da ging es ja immer noch um
Verleumdung und Schadenersatz und so
weiter ich kann mir vorher schon
vorstellen dass er damit jetzt noch mal
zum marktte geht weil das Thema ist
immer noch nach wie vor in aller Munde
und er ist einer der letzten Vertreter
der sagt ihr habt da den falschen am
Wickel den bisschen Verdächtigen
Christian Brückner ihr müsst auf die
Eltern schauen kommt denn überhaupt
jetzt ein bisschen Bewegung in den Fall
kommt da Aufklärung rein Christian
Brückner sitzt weiterhin im Gefängnis
wie geht es da weiter im Fall Maddie das
muss man so klar sagen ist keine
Bewegung die Ermittlungen stagnieren
insofern als das den Anklägern in
Braunschweig der finale Beweis fehlt den
Sie brauchen um Christian Brückner für
die Entführung der Ermordung von Maddie
Mercan anzuklagen es kommt aber in
andere Fälle Bewegungen es sind ja quasi
als Beifang in den Ermittlungen den den
ermittelten Beamten beim BKA und bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft Hinweise ins Netz
gegangen die möglicherweise andere
Straftaten Christian Brückner zu Last
legen und es ist damit zu rechnen schon
seit geraumer Zeit aber jetzt ist glaube
ich wirklich unmittelbar jetzt
unmittelbar bevor dass da Anklage
erhoben wird es geht um eine weitere
Vergewaltigung in Praia da Lusche wo
mehr die verschwunden ist es geht um
zwei Fälle von sexuellen Missbrauch von
Kindern und da hört man dass die ermitt
so weit sind dass man möglicherweise
zeitnah mit einer Anklage rechnen kann
und dann könnten vielleicht auch weitere
Details ans Licht kommen im Fall Madlen
mckenn dieser Fall der noch so viele
offene Fragen hat und uns immer noch
nach all den Jahren tief bewegt kein
Feldhaus danke für Deinen Besuch hier im
Studio
[Musik]